الحكومه العراقيه تعلن انتهاء اكبر عمليه
صحيه من نوعها لتلقيح اكثر من نصف مليون
طفل ممن يحتاجون بشده لتلك اللقاحات
لانقاذ حياتهم من الخطر وزاره الصحه
العراقيه وبدعم من السعوديه وامريكا
ومنظمتي اليونيسف والصحه العالميه تمكنت
من تقديم اكثر من مليون و300 الف جرعه
لقاح الى نحو
50018 الف طفل بينهم ما يزيد على 330 الف
طفل تم تطعيمهم ضد مرض الحصبه الاكثر عدوى
كما جرى تطعيم نحو 50 الف طفل ممن لم يتم
تحصينهم او فاتتهم اللقاحات وعملت الفرق
الطبيه ايضا على توعيه اكثر من مليون شخص
من الاهالي حول اهميه اللقاحات وتحصين
الاطفال حمله اللقاحات لاقت ترحيبا كبيرا
من الاهل لحمايه اطفالهم فيما وصفتها
منظمات دوليه بانها مهمه للغايه
وتعهدت بمواصله تامينيها
اللقاحات هي الاستراتيجيه الاكثر امانا
لحمايه الاطفال من الامراض وتلتزم
اليونيسف بضمان وصول اللقاحات الى كل طفل
في العراق الصحه العراقيه اعتبرت حمله
اللقاحات مرحله هامه لبلوغ التغطيه الصحيه
الشامله في البلاد لقد حققت هذه الحمله
نجاحا كبيرا في ضمان عدم اهمال اي طفل في
العراق وتقول منظمه اليونيسف والصحه
العالميه ان فرقهما تعمل بشكل مكثف لانقاذ
الاطفال حول العالم من الامراض والاوبئه
وتمكينهم من النمو بصحه جيده من خلال
استخدام السياسات والبرامج المبنيه على
اسس علميه وطبيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات